foreign
starts this hour in Minnesota hi
Samantha how are you
yeah Dave this is Allison thanks for
taking my call oh shoot I'm sorry I said
my name
oh boy um starting off good here my
question is that
um I am wondering whether I need to sell
my home to pay off the rest of my debt
or whether I need to accept a gift from
my parents to pay off the debt
okay uh how old are you
I'm 35. and how much do you owe in your
home
I owe about 250. how much other debt do
you have
about 12 000.
I have um worked that down quite a bit
thanks to your help
um but it's I keep on bouncing back and
forth between baby step one and two now
um just based on recent events that keep
putting things in my path okay like what
um but like last summer my AC went out
um this year I've had a lot of vet bills
and medical what do you mean
I make 80 000 a year okay well vet bills
in an AC should not [ __ ] you making
80 grand a year
I'm sorry yeah I have made a lot of
property pay off 12 000 if we took all
this out of the equation if it was just
up to you
just up to me
I'll probably get it out so you know and
then I mean if I took on like another
weekend job probably you know six to
eight months yeah that sounds right okay
and so uh and and so you don't have to
sell your house to get out of debt
my my house is a little bit more than my
um than the 25 that you recommend though
of my a little bit more doesn't make me
sell it
okay your house is not out of line I
mean your house is close to out of line
but it's not it's not 50 of your
take-home pay
no no you know it's it's it might be 28
or something right
no well with the HOA it's 30 percent
it's not going to kill you this is a
guideline to keep you from being house
poor so it's not a it's not a Pharisee
thing where if you're one and a half
percent over you got to sell your house
it's not it's not what we're doing we're
just trying to say don't be house poor
and you're not house poor I'd rather you
be a little bit lower but I don't think
you have to sell your house unless you
want to sell your house okay so if Mom
and Dad give you twelve thousand dollars
uh what's the downside of that are they
controlling are they going to be
giving you a hard time or
no no I think you know the I would want
to pay it back to them you know anyway
just you know before they retire that's
not it's not a gift that's a loan
so the downside is they don't really
have the twelve thousand they're too
broken they have it how much do they
have are they millionaires
yes then they don't need twelve thousand
dollars from you
it's a gift
hello
yeah I'm here okay
how can you not accept a gift
I just don't want to be feel like I'm
enabling myself in a situation that is
going to that is that isn't good for me
like because for example the loan I have
on my house is a 30-year loan it's not a
15-year loan like you recommend so I you
know I've been kind of coaching myself
to get in more of the mindset where I
get into you know a house 15-year loan
set
um you know interest rate and then um
and potentially sell this house and I
just feel like because I accept that
that gift from them I'm kind of enabling
myself
no the 12 000 is going away still the
house is still exactly the same
situation
so it's not enabling the house it's
enabling the debt but you've already
broken the cycle on the debt haven't you
yeah I I think so
um I hope so I mean just the fact that
yeah have they given you money before
and you've messed back up and fallen off
the wagon
they have given they helped me with the
down payment on my house and I did pay
that back to them though okay
all right
okay okay
here's the thing you're 35 years old you
do not have to prove your maturity to
your parents
by repaying
it's not like well she needs to learn
her lesson
no you don't that's not that's not the
thing okay that's just not a thing if
you can accept the gift and there's no
strings attached and your parents aren't
Freaks and they're not dogging you about
going on vacation after you got a twelve
thousand dollar gift from them or
something like that then I think you
should learn to accept the gift you need
to learn to be a a receiver as well as a
giver and no it is not a loan do not
take it as a loan either don't take it
or take it as a gift
and um and I don't think that makes you
irresponsible and I don't think you're
enabling nothing you've told me
indicates that I would tell you you know
I would
Dave I think I hear some self-loathing
or some you're chill still punishing
yourself like you've bought into the
baby steps and you believe it and listen
you've done a great job to get to this
moment yeah you don't need to feel
guilty about receiving a gift that will
Fast Forward you'll be able to start
paying your house off and I just sense
that you feel just the fact you said I I
don't want to enable like you're still
feeling shame and guilt over maybe past
financial decisions I think you got to
be free from that yeah rear view mirrors
are smaller than windshields and that's
called Grace
um
so you look in the rearview mirror
enough to not to stay aligned and but it
doesn't Define your future your future
is defined by the windshield so here's
what I would do if I woke up in your
shoes and then you can go do whatever
you want okay number one as I said I'm
not going to do anything as a loan
period no relative loans no loans we're
out of the debt business period shifting
it from relative to relative debt from
credit card debts dumb idea just pay it
off forget it okay if you're going to
take it take it as a gift and a smile no
strings attached no problems number one
number two as far that leaves us with
just the house then and the eighty
thousand dollar income and a 30-year
mortgage is the thirty percent of your
income including HOA do you have to sell
that no should you re-evaluate it yes
and I would what I would do if I woke up
in your shoes as I'd take the gift I'd
pay off the debt I'd set my budget up
and I'd work on my career to get my
income up enough that I can start paying
this house like a 15 at a reasonable
rate so if you got your income to 100
000 this whole thing changes and so I'm
gonna give myself off 36 months to get
my income to 100 to 110 otherwise I'm
going to talk about selling the house if
I'm stuck at 80 for the next five years
I'm probably going to sell the house but
if I can see a curve on my income going
up and this house starts to be a smaller
and smaller percentage of my income
therefore I can put it on a 15-year
schedule because I'm debt free because I
accepted the gift and I'm on a budget
then I'm keeping the house but um
nothing
um
uh you are you are a very precise very
detailed person
and that works to your advantage in this
case you are I've got a little bit of
paralysis of the analysis
and so um I in other words cut yourself
some slack kiddo you're doing so much
better than your emotions and your
sentence structure tells us you think
you're doing so I think you're doing
great